foreign
[Music]
business it is the end of an era LG is
one of the most iconic brands in the
world as they produce everything from
washers and dryers to smartphones and
the TVs for decades they were the pride
and joy of South Korea along with
Samsung and they still very much hold
that status within the country but
outside of South Korea LG has had a
rough couple of years especially with
smartphones for ears LG was trying to
break into the smartphone space and
established themselves like Samsung and
Apple but year after year LG walked away
with a bigger and bigger loss during the
worst of it LG was down four and a half
billion dollars within a matter of just
six years and the reality was that they
could only justify such losses for so
long and eventually they wanted out so
they started looking for buyers but no
one wanted to buy a money pit that
needed to compete against Apple and
Samsung so with no choice left LG
decided to make the hard decision to
completely scrap their smartphone
business in April of 2021 but LG's
Outlook wasn't always so pessimistic at
one point it seemed like LG was here to
stay given their massive presence for
example LG became the world's third
largest smartphone maker back in 2013
and they held this title with the North
America until the day they shut down and
it's not like LG was stagnating or
getting too comfortable either if
anything they were doing the exact
opposite as they were consistently
innovating and Taking Chances in fact LG
was actually the first company to make a
capacitive touchscreen phone way back in
2006. they followed this up with the
flexible OLED displays in 2014 modular
smartphones in 2016 dual screen phones
in 2019 and as well phones in 2020 we
should also note that LG wasn't set on
trying to maximize profits and screw
over customers either they not only kept
the headphone jack for one to two years
longer than everyone else but they even
tried improving it by integrating a quad
DAC into their phones from the outside
and seemed like LG had literally
everything going for them they were a
household name with a bunch of resources
and that they were constantly trying to
outdo not just the competition but
themselves so what happened to LG
foreign
taking a look back LG's eventual demise
can be traced back to their very first
smartphone the LG product back in
December of 2006. as we previously
touched on the Prada was the first phone
to ever have a capacitive touch screen
and the LG was even suspicious that
apple had ripped off their design but
you've probably never even heard of this
phone which brings us into LG's number
one mistake non-existent marketing this
was likely a trade that LG brought with
them from the appliance space with
refrigerators and washers marketing it
is not exactly one of your top concerns
for most people these are Necessities
that they only buy when their old one
breaks the key is strong availability
offering Great Value and having a
reputation for reliability practicality
sells appliances not Showmanship LG
approach the smartphone market with the
same mentality they figured that if they
could just make a strong product people
would be lining up to buy their phones
but the key difference between
appliances and smartphones was that one
was a necessity and the other was a
luxury at least back in the day when
smartphones people wanted something that
was desired something that was exclusive
something that gave them social status
Apple offered exactly this they had
their massive Keynotes that garnered
tens of millions of views even if you
had a no intention of buying an iPhone
you knew about a new one that Apple just
released and the people who wanted them
well some of them would literally wait
for days outside of Apple Stores to be
the first ones to get the new iPhone
what did LG do on the other hand well
they dropped smartphones as if they were
iOS updates actually no wait I take that
back iOS updates actually get more press
the LG launch events took place during
Korea time which made it hard for
Western audiences to tune in but it
wouldn't matter even if they did tune in
given that LG didn't build any tension
or hype their phones would have become
available in Korea the exact same day
also there wasn't any sort of
synchronized International launch the
launch dates for America and Europe were
simply when Logistics channels could get
them there and oftentimes this took
months again this seems to be a
lingering attribute of their Appliance
business people don't hold out on buying
a stove because a new one is just around
the corner so the specifics of when a
new product makes its way to Western
markets didn't really matter with
smartphones however people want a the
latest and the greatest in fact many
people hold out for several months just
so that they can get the latest right
when it drops I know you're watching so
much of LG success in the smartphone
space in the early days simply came from
the fact that they were already an
established cell phone maker and a brand
but other than that they didn't have
much going for them and when more
competition entered the scene they would
feel the squeeze
foreign
Market continued to mature we started to
see smartphones transition from being a
luxury to being a necessity this gave
rise to a whole new demographic of
people who were just looking for a
practical value device companies like
Google OnePlus xiaomi and Huawei have
basically built their entire smartphone
business around this Market you would
think that this was the perfect
opportunity for LG they were already in
the space making practical devices so
all they had to do was double down and
pump out some marketing about how much
value they offer but on Gia obviously
didn't do that you see in 2012 and 2013
LG finally realized their marketing
blunder they needed to make LG
smartphones the latest and the greatest
and they needed to make them unique
special and exclusive with that in mind
they decided to go after their premium
Market which isn't a bad thing LG did
have a shot at taking on Samsung and
maybe even overtaking them but well LG
had the right idea they also kind of
didn't LG was right in that they had to
offer the latest and the greatest but
they were wrong in thinking that they
actually had to make the latest and
greatest while they were talking about
Mercedes or apple the key to making the
latest and greatest isn't actually to
make the latest and the greatest the key
is to make a strong product and pair it
with exceptional positioning LG however
approached this from a literal sense and
Incorporated some wacky stuff into their
phones a few of their experiments
actually turned out to be a trend
setting for example the LG G5 was the
first smartphone to support an ultrawide
camera way back in 2016. since then
Ultra wide cameras have become a
standard amongst premium smartphones but
most of LG's experiments didn't play out
quite as well starting with the LG G
Flex in 2013. around this time curved
TVs were a hot thing so LG figured that
they should bring this future to
smartphones but this Choice ended up
aging as well as curved TVs themselves
soon after we saw the LG V10 in 2015.
this phone came with two unique features
one the phone had two front-facing
cameras and the two the phone had a
secondary screen at the top that
displayed a taskbar type of thing that
never really caught on moving forward we
saw the LG G5 in 2016. the selling
feature of this phone was the fact that
it was modular during a time when
everyone was following the apple way and
preventing smartphone upgrades LG
decided to give Choice back to the
consumers but LG's Partners never pull
through it and launched accessories that
made the modularity actually worthwhile
nonetheless LG continued pushing forward
they introduced a dual screen phone with
the g8x and a swivel phone with the LG
Wing but all these features made LG
phones as expensive as iPhones they
didn't make them as appealing as iPhones
LG simply became known as the smartphone
producer with the gimmicks
foreign
to pile up at LG they naturally became
more desperate her gimmicks became more
outrageous and her Focus became more
tunnel visioned everything centered
around how do we get more attention and
how do we sell more units this makes
sense given that volume was by far their
biggest pain point they simply weren't
able to sell enough units to make up for
their monster r d expenses so they
naturally shifted all of their focus
into garnering more sales from a macro
perspective this was a great choice
given that this is exactly what LG had
been lacking for so long but
unfortunately this came with the cost of
sacrificing current users LG started to
drop the ball when it came to software
hardware and UI optimization for example
while LG phones had massive batteries on
the spec sheet the real world
performance was average at the best due
to the phones being so inefficient
software updates became few and far
between it and several LG phone phones
were played with boot loop issues and
they didn't take long for LG to become
infamous for their software issues but
these issues didn't just stop at
software LG started having hardware
issues as well on the LG v20 for example
the camera glass was for some reason
extremely fragile LG phones were also
played with battery overheating issues
microphone issues network issues and the
fingerprint sensor issues LG's whole
business was centered around making
practical Electronics but somehow their
new smartphones were anything but
practical and to make things worse it
didn't seem like LG was truly trying to
fix any of this they had gone so far
down the latest and the greatest rabbit
hole that all they seemingly wanted to
do was create something that was super
out there and Garner their attention of
the media the purpose of their new
phones were to Simply get you to buy
they didn't care about your experience
using the phone or your feedback this
strategy may work alright if products
that people only buy once but with
phones people are constantly replacing
them every few years not to mention
people use their phones for hours every
single day so it didn't take them long
to notice LG did eventually try to make
it up to customers by offering super
long warranties for the phones affected
by bootloops for example LG offered
warranties for up to 30 months but this
is not the type of impression that you
can reverse once people believe that LG
phones offer a crappy experience they're
gonna hold that belief forever and now
that even existing users were turning on
the company LG's fate was sealed
foreign
in the end LG is a perfect example of
just because you're successful in one
industry does not mean that you'll be
successful in another throughout their
entire smartphone run they were
constantly at the wrong place at the
wrong time in the early days when the
market was filled with luxury buyers now
these marketing and positioning simply
wasn't up to par then when the General
market joined the scene LG finally
decided to go after their premium Market
but not with strong marketing but
without their gimmicks that rarely hit
and finally LG became so desperate on
getting new sales that they started
completely ignoring their core Market of
existing users with such fatal flaws
it's no wonder that after 15 years in
the smartphone industry all LG had to
show for it was billions of dollars
worth of losses and hundreds of millions
of angry customers looking forward it
doesn't seem like LG will be restarting
their smartphone business anytime soon
in fact the company is doing better
without smartphones so it's probably
best that they stick to what they're
good at but hey while LG wasn't able to
make it within the smartphone space
themselves we may very well see many of
your gimmicks make a comeback in a much
better way but only time will tell did
you ever own an LG smartphone comment
that down below also drop a like if you
hope that LG smartphones rest in peace
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community suggest future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
foreign